it's always I'm not managing to my
wonderful MacBook you all love it
where is that present present good so
yeah cool so good to everybody I'm
Valentin go get Josh really it's very
simple name and I will be talking about
yeah so you can see how it is written
it's very simple I will be talking about
micro services at solando how many of
you do not know what solando is okay
good how many of you actually bought
anything at solando ah nice it's
actually about ten percent good so we
are quite big and we became big not so
fast
the we started growing I should
cylinders have around seven years old
and I started at solando more than five
and a half years ago so I'm a kind of a
dinosaur it's Amanda so we started at
billing now we grow our technology
department grows and not only technology
department so now we actually have these
are only the technology hubs of solando
and the technology team grows really
fast so now we are 1200 I think two
months ago to us 1100 so we're really
growing fast but it was not always like
that
I mean we grew fast always but we were
not so big always so we we start it as a
small prototype and the prototype
like this so we used PHP we used my
sequel you probably know this this is
typical way to start the yeah anything
actually so but this this model didn't
really work for a long time when I
started that solando five and a half
years ago the site was growing with the
kind of 100 percent per month it was
quite an interesting time we were
actually the biggest users of Magento at
some moment and then Megantic just
didn't work anymore so we decided to do
the reboot so it was a cool project I
started little bit later when when it
started and I was working for five weeks
without weekends towards cool time what
we did we actually built we rewrote
everything in Java
I used Posterous and store procedures
there so I'm talking about this I was
talking about this on different
conferences if you have any questions I
can answer them and use Python for
automation we automated as much as
possible because with these grows and so
you need to automate and Python was
chosen as the language of choice for
automation purposes now we are growing
and so again history in context we built
the world of macro services so micro
services were not so small as micro
services are supposed to be but it was
not also a huge monolith so we we've
done our job not bad and the system was
very efficient and it still works and
still generates this 3 billion in
revenue per year but we have a problem
we had a problem so our developers
started to to to want something more
they want something cool they want
something
exciting yeah
the we had the problem of as you call it
in corporate language and wanted
attrition people started to leave so
what we did we announced radical agility
so called the radical agility the idea
of radical agility that teams are
getting autonomy they get purpose and
what else yeah and they actually achieve
mastery what does it mean actually
this means that autonomous teams can
choose their own technology stack
autonomous teams are responsible for
what they do and we decided to move away
from our data centers into AWS some I
see some smiles already in the audience
actually you probably understand what
what kind of problems we have and and
and started to see and actually this
talk is about problems and how we try to
solve them so autonomy is not on our key
and to support autonomy you have to work
hard you you need to have an army you
have to have police you have to whatever
it's kind of so one of the pillars that
we used to to support autonomy of the
teams was troops infrastructure and on
this picture it looks very simple yeah
we use docker containers everything is
cool blah blah blah
how it is like how it looks in reality
so it's this happens when you try to be
consistent and be how do you call it
apply it now compliant with the audit
requirements from the German authorities
yes
so Stoops is this the system for respond
possible corporations that want to run
their business in SS this is what we
managed to create to kind of the minimum
amount of components and infrastructure
that we have to do to ensure that
everything that we do everything that we
run in production is auditable
everything is fine and cool and we know
who is doing what and so on and another
point was that we said we will use
microservices what is inside the micro
service we don't care the most important
part is REST API and kind of you that
this micro service is collaborate with
it communicate with each other the
problem of course happens here with ETL
processes the what does it mean I will
try to explain now again going back into
the history and I will go to kind of
classical history so it's very simple
world so we have developers DBAs
business intelligence they all work they
know their roles developers bring data
to DBAs DBAs give data to analysts and
business and data scientists this is the
classical world so this is how our
vintage applications work and they work
wonderfully because in in many cases
developer teams even don't know that the
data scientists and business
intelligence are extracting data from
their databases and reality is of course
bigger we have a lot of services a lot
of databases and extracting data into
the data warehouse it has some
disadvantages it has some advantages but
still even if it has advantages its
entities it doesn't work for micro
services so what is the data integration
in the world of them of the micro
services so we have small micro services
they have
all have some own databases we have
happy developers we have a little bit
dot DB is not knowing what to do now and
we have business intelligence guys going
crazy because they cannot access the
data any longer so one of the solutions
that we have suggest now is that micro
services not only change data using just
a REST API eyes but they also exchange
data using cues so we are building some
very thin layer of a Kafka or Kinesis so
it's kind of underlying system agnostic
system broker Nakata eventbus that is
providing security and authentication
authorization and kind of registration
of the entities into the bus and allow
the systems to exchange data actually
this is the typical way how people want
to develop actually this is how I want
to do them to develop it I don't
actually want people to use databases at
all the the best persistence layer for
your micro services should be the event
bus but I will not go into details with
that because it's kind of there I cannot
talk about our cool projects that we did
to support the wrong architecture yes so
and the idea is that business
intelligence can extract the data from
our event bus subscribing to everything
that is flowing there having access to
everything so what are the typical
problems of actually writing events into
the event buses and this this are
problems that many developers do not
actually understand very well this is
how people want to do it so if the
application has database they people
usually tend to
say okay we will write events to the to
the event bus or to the good Kafka
whatever and then we write to the
database or wait we first write to
database then write to event bus yeah so
it's actually problem you need a
two-phase commit and it will be slow so
it's very difficult to implement
correctly if you don't if you care about
not losing changes in your persistence
layer so another way to do this that
would be actually make your life much
easier and let the people who care about
the consistency of data and your systems
sleep well is actually extracting the
data directly from your persistence
layer so what what we did for Postgres I
said is not we of care of course so the
Postgres supports now from recent
versions the extraction of data through
the logical replication stream and there
are several products the PG logical is
written by second quadrant bottled water
is a confluent product confluent was
done by the guys who actually created
Kafka and tab on that we wrote it's a
purely Python project to extract
snapshots from the databases and push
the snapshot into the into the queue so
this model is to demonstrate it a little
bit better so you have this snapshot
extraction tool you have a logical
replication instruction plug-in and you
actually can extract the consistent
snapshots and follow the changes
afterwards using the snapshot using the
logical replication extractor so peyten
wonderful tool for doing many things
including the prototyping so
you actually can play around the psycho
PG the the Morris official Python driver
for Postgres is it's not yet merged but
the pull request is functioning
correctly so you can actually check out
and see how this thing works you can
actually play around with the changes
that are flowing from the database you
can see them in the form of JSON objects
on your actually real Python objects in
your application so it's really cool
thing and I really it would be really
really nice to hear your feedback about
other projects that are related to this
topic this is mostly Python code another
possibility would be if you're on a WS
the Adobe DB has support for dynamic
streams this is more or less the same
but really working just by the click of
the button and you can extract data from
from kind of the stream of changes that
happening to your data an OTB cluster is
actually pushed into Kinesis like queue
and you can directly build your
event-driven wrongly builds event-driven
application using this technology the I
wanted to put also the slide about
Cassandra Cassandra doesn't have this
support and there is the big ticket on
this on kind of recovery of data change
events from from the cluster but because
of the architectural problems it's a lot
of work to be done there and I think
they need at least a year or so to come
closer to this kind of a solution ok we
have our bus we have our so how how much
time do we have huh wonderful we have
our bus we have so now now the question
is how do we actually transport
data into our business intelligence or
data science infrastructure and this is
psyche so psyche is a crazy name
actually we we call our projects quite
crazy names because our teams also can
use their own names choose their own way
we have team nobody for example who is
responsible for the product nobody okay
there's a team name and Psyche is a
Javanese not Japanese Japanese name for
queue and nobody knows if it's true
because they used Google Translate for
that so yeah psyche data platform
actually that data Lake was invented by
current probably earlier the Krannert
actually made the first architecture
diagram of data lake in 1546 you see
here the the cue of kind of messages
coming into the purifying fountains and
then you have the analysts feeding on
the data everything fine but we we need
a more modern version of this thing so
we I will now explain a little bit more
how the Hausa a key works so currently
say the psychic structs data from the
data queue and puts it in another queue
i will cover this little bit later why
so afterwards they're pushing it into
the toka system this is also a [ __ ]
so all these names are Japanese and I
keep forgetting the meaning of this
words but you can look look them up so I
checked that they are not no swear words
there and tukang is more or less the s3
materializer for data that is flowing
into the event queues so what token does
is keeps track of the metadata
materializes data into the three and
then allows
ah less extracting this data from s3
using this better data into the data
warehouses it also also allows to create
more materialization engines like for
example yeah so I already talked about
it a little bit it also cleans a little
bit event stream and then it also allows
to materialize into different databases
for example if you have something else
not not the data warehouse system but
some smaller forecast system you can
actually fetch some parts of the data
that has interesting for you for example
information about prices or information
about articles being changed or created
so products into something different so
you have you you see that there is still
a place on this on this diagram so more
is coming what what are they there so if
you compare the two processes actually
there are only advantages other than one
point actually the it's very difficult
now for the business intelligence people
to really control the structure of of
something that is flowing so we are
trying to solve this problem by this
Naqada register of there is some to
enable to register the types in the
riccati and then check that the types
that are flowing to the event bus
actually correspond to what is
registered but there are some problems
and discussions about this types in
narcotic project so you are really so
all these projects are developed open
source so you really welcome to look
into the codes into the pool requests
and have your kind of ideas also given
to us so yeah this
trust for correctness of data on the
real team so we never trusted anybody
before now we live in the world where we
have to trust and actually it makes
people happier when we we trust them but
we still have to check that they are
doing their job right so what else what
can we do actually with the data from
that we store there so we also can
actually produce analyze the data in
real time so we did quite extensive
comparison of two systems flink and
spark for the reasons of processing data
in near real-time and flink one and one
of the topics were flink one also was
the reaction time for when we had
problems they really the community is
really much much faster than this than
they our community so yeah actually I
have a I have a nice slide here and also
a link to the to the blog post on our
tech blog about the comparison of link
and spark so really if you don't know
what link is have a look if you know
what link is then I'm actually next week
there is a meet-up and solando office
about link so you're welcome to come and
listen to the guys who wrote linkage
it also flink also as spark of course
supports a lot of connectors and you can
actually directly write - sparks -
elasticsearch system for examples and
the current implementation uses
elasticsearch but the idea is that we
not only use elasticsearch and something
else though we if we have the machine
that is working there nicely then we
actually can enable data scientist
to deploy code in the managed flink
cluster and they will be able also to
calculate and get some interesting
insights from the data that is flowing
real-time from all the systems that we
have one of the use cases for real-time
business process monitoring is for
example you can really check that all
the processes and business business
processes work as expected you can yeah
I already talked about I'm somehow
talking a little bit ahead of the slides
sorry for that yes what else and there's
still spirit still space here so
actually what what what can we do so
here actually the data like the idea is
that as three as as just a dump of data
is not enough you you don't want to
build a data swamp you need to have a
data lake that you can actually be able
to access afterwards and the data Lake
project now has several prototypes of
how to persist data into a three so that
it's then easily accessible through
systems like HDFS or hive or whatever so
now there are a lot of discussions in
the team about these topics and I will
be really very interested also to
discuss these topics with anybody who is
also doing this kind of projects in
their companies yes open source as I
said we do we perceive the idea that you
should do everything open source that
can be open sourced and every time when
the project is being started at solando
we more or less discuss can we do this
project open source if we cannot do this
open source then we have to really find
the reason why not to
what is what is stopping us yeah so is
it really the competitive advantage that
we will be giving to somebody away if we
open source this if so one of course has
to consider all the possibilities and
all the dangers for a commercial company
but we are really trying to do as much
open source as possible the very
interesting part especially for the
patent community I think is this link
with the connection this makes it
possible to to create microservices rest
with restful api is in a matter of
seconds just just by defining swagga
file and using this swagga file as the
routing engine for your service so the
only thing that you have to do is to
define in Swaggart files the entry
points for the for the Python methods
that should be called when you are using
this or that call and that's it
it's it's really cool it makes
especially prototyping really really
really fast so and easy we have also the
same project for play to to exchange the
play way of using root files but yes I
think I think we still I'm somehow very
fast again and I thought it's crazy I am
I thought I was not was I fast guys no
was i was i boring
ok good so then then you have a lot of
time to ask me questions
Thank You Verity okay so do we have
questions yes we do
hi I got a question it's about if you
have so many independent teams and the
bus in the middle how can you get sure
that the data is always matched and have
the same keys and so on
so isn't it a huge mass of data and no
one knows what it is we have experience
in huge masses of data yes and we are
trying to do everything to avoid this
mess and one of the tools to avoid this
mess is the API guild so we actually
have the concept of guilds that are
cross team structures and several teams
for example the technology guild or API
guild actually curated guilds so to say
so for example API guild is curated by
our senior architect and his team and
and the team contains many volunteers
from different teams who actually
volunteer to review the api's that
people described and ours we I also have
here I think oh I don't I forgot to put
it here so actually if you go to our
github page we have our REST API
guidelines published as an open-source
project and there we are defining kind
of the main principles that we want to
that the teams actually follow when
defining the api's and mmm I think also
includes the data modeling part so
the entities that you expose through
this Web API now it's called actually
open API API yes open API definition
api's they should be consistent with the
entities that actually are pushed into
the data lake and what we it's not yet
implemented but on the roadmap for the
event bus it's also automatic discovery
of these entities that are defined by
the projects so there we hope that the
streamlined process of review of the
api's will help us to reduce the horror
and cows of data just being declared
correctly by everybody so did I answer
your question yeah yeah when you
distribute data in the database level
usually you run into the problem of
dependencies so how do you deal with
changes for example you have data in the
table you use replication tools to
replicate that somewhere else you have a
consumer the consumer is not prepared
for your database layout to change and
in an API you can use different versions
you have blue/green deployment and so on
how do you deal with that on a database
level we hope so the the for now this
this is on the level of prototypes so we
are kind of collecting this data now
from several services only but the idea
is that we actually mark every schema
that is published with a version of
course and the the whole idea of restful
api is is actually the same so you need
to if you are extending your entities
then you're usually extending them so
that they are backwards compatible it's
more less the same I think these
questions are answered by the restful
principles better than by something else
I see you are not satisfied we also have
experience of a very consistent way of
extending data entities in our Postgres
infrastructure and yeah we collected a
lot of experience there and I will be
really happy to to show you what we have
there so if you will be interested yes
of course I have a question so you said
several times that the architecture
where each micro services on local
database that stream and even clock to
the bus is not the right one and you
should be doing something else can you
explain what should be something else
and why it's a bad idea to the to do it
this way mostly the my problem with the
approach is actually this this approach
that I showed you that the the problem
with a double right so so you you you
have to if you have your database as
part of your application and you are not
persisting data directly into the
eventbus then then you have the problem
where is the primary source of your ways
the truth is that in the event pass or
is it in the database and if the
database doesn't support two-phase
commits you don't have a even
theoretical possibility to do it
correctly and keep your data consistent
so that's why I think this is just wrong
architecture and if you write data only
to to the bus and
and have a small other service actually
what what does this database do it this
database allows you to recover the state
after restart so this can be done by
actually replaying events from the bus
if the snapshotting infrastructure is
nicely built and another thing is fast
access to data and in most cases it
would be it can be used as a cache yeah
so it's kind of in most cases it's a
cache so if you want your if you need a
cache then build a separate service that
extracts the data from the bus and and
builds this cache for you that is not
relevant to your actually business logic
but there are a lot of problems there as
well because for example locks and
distributed locks and the concurrency
issues have to be correctly addressed
yeah do we have more questions well just
because it's you you know so you said at
the beginning that you're running
everything in containers and you have
the database inside the container
understand how do you manage persistent
volume with docker and you have some
kind of orchestration for this or first
of all I never said that we have
databases and containers but we do have
databases and containers and this is our
DBA team was swearing like like semen
when building this thing into containers
but actually now we have a working
solution for that and it's a Patroni
system yeah now one of the projects on
the
on the open source page for Postgres for
example we have the appliances for post
players we have appliances for cassandra
and you have to do a lot of additional
trickery to really ensure that your
underlying system will work correctly
with your docker but I think I think it
is the the container is not the biggest
problem there it's just the AWS is the
very is a system that you cannot trust
and this brings you into the situation
where you cannot so your discs that you
yeah you cannot trust the discs the only
thing in AWS that you can trust is s3
with eleven nines I think they have
availability so EBS is have I think
weaker SLA is then some other systems
there so it's kind of you you this is
just to make your life perceivable
easier but yeah so you cannot build this
systems databases trusting the EBS for
example you you have to build a cluster
that is correctly running and if you
lose the one of the machines that your
cluster survives it so you you shouldn't
trust don't trust the system do you have
any questions are people wanting some
break and a little bit of e yes okay I
think it's time to split and thanks a
lot for your wonderful talk